ISRAELI SPY.
BRET.
>> Bret: BRYAN THANK YOU.
LAWMAKERS IN THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY AND THE CURRENT
ADMINISTRATION ARE DEALING WITH
A NEW POTENTIALLY EXPLOSIVE
ISSUE.
A WHISTLE-BLOWER COMPLAINT OVER
AN ALLEGED PROMISE MADE BY
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO A FOREIGN
LEADER.
THE CASE IS SHROUDED IN MYSTERY
AND WAS THE SUBJECT OF A CLOSED
DOOR CLASSIFIED MEETING TODAY ON
CAPITOL HILL.
THE PRESIDENT IS ALREADY PUSHING
BACK IN THE HOUSE INTEL CHAIR IS
THREATENING TO GO TO COURT.
CHIEF INTELLIGENCE CORRESPONDENT
CATHERINE HERRIDGE HAS THE
LATEST TONIGHT.
>> BEHIND CLOSED DOORS ON
CAPITOL HILL, THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY INSPECTOR GENERAL
MICHAEL ATKINSON BRIEFED
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS ON THE
HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE.
THE DEMOCRATIC CHAIRMAN SAID THE
SESSION DID NOT CONFIRM MEDIA
REPORTING FOR THE WHISTLE-BLOWER
COMPLAINT INVOLVES A PHONE CALL
FOR THE PRESIDENT MADE A PROMISE
TO A FOREIGN LEADER.
STILL, HE SET THE THRESHOLD FOR
CONGRESSIONAL NOTIFICATION WAS
NOT IN THE INTELLIGENCE CHIEF
BLOCKED IT.
>> IT WAS AN URGENT MATTER, THE
DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE HAS MADE THE
UNPRECEDENTED DECISION NOT TO
SHARE THE COMPLAINT WITH
CONGRESS.
>> ON TWITTER, PRESIDENT TRUMP
CALLED THE PLACE "ANOTHER FAKE
NEWS STORY" AND REFERRING TO THE
FACT THAT OTHER OFFICIALS WERE
LIKELY LISTENING TO HIS CALLS,
"IS ANYBODY DUMB ENOUGH TO
BELIEVE THAT I WOULD SAY
SOMETHING INAPPROPRIATE WITH A
FOREIGN LEADER WHILE IN SUCH A
POTENTIAL HEAVILY POPULATED
CALL"?
AMERICAN LEADERS ARE OFTEN
MEASURED BY WHAT THEY TELL
FOREIGN LEADERS.
THEN-PRESIDENT OBAMA FAMOUSLY
TOLD THE OUTGOING RUSSIAN
PRESIDENT HE WOULD HAVE "MORE
FLUX ABILITY TO NEGOTIATE A
DEFENSE ISSUE AFTER THE
ELECTION."
TODAY THE HOUSE MINORITY LEADER
WAS SKEPTICAL.
>> ANOTHER MEDIA ALWAYS WANTS TO
RUSH WHEN THEY THINK SOMETHING
SENSATIONALIST AND NINE TIMES
OUT OF TEN WE FIND OUT A LOT OF
THAT IS NOT TRUE.
I THINK "THE NEW YORK TIMES" HAS
EXPERIENCED THAT JUST IN THE
LAST WEEK.
>> THAN A WHISTLE-BLOWER
COMPLAINT MAY FURTHER STRESS THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY AND
ADMINISTRATION.
THERE ARE REMAINING LEGAL
QUESTIONS OVER WHETHER ACTING
DNR McGUIRE CAN SHARE
INTELLIGENCE FROM EXECUTIVE
BRANCH COMMUNICATIONS.
>> WE DO KNOW THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE HAS BEEN INVOLVED IN THE
DECISION TO WITHHOLD THAT
INFORMATION FROM CONGRESS.
WE DO NOT KNOW BECAUSE WE CANNOT
GET AN ANSWER TO THE QUESTION
ABOUT WHETHER THE WHITE HOUSE IS
ALSO INVOLVED IN PREVENTING THIS
INFORMATION FROM COMING TO
CONGRESS.
>> THE ACTING DIRECTOR OF
NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE IS
SCHEDULED TO PUBLICLY TESTIFY
NEXT WEEK.
MANY DEMOCRATS SAY THEY ARE
WILLING TO GO TO COURT OVER THE
ISSUE WHILE REPUBLICANS CALL
THAT SCHIFF STATEMENT IS